you know why I say she'd be good at
pokers because she can lie to your face
yeah without with without twitching
without with no tell you'd be like
because she feels like her lies are just
but I'm obviously I've never met her I
don't know but like there are some
people who feel as though like they are
entitled to lie like their means are so
honorable that they don't feel remorse
like people who Flinch when they lie or
give some tell like they feel on some
level guilty about I don't think they
believe that they're lying well that's
true too I really think that there are
people that there are people like
narcissistic yeah it's Saul alinsky's
rules for radical yes right it's like
yeah I might be lying but I'm doing it
for good yeah it's what it's what is the
goal yeah that's in mind and justifies
the means what's that mean where they
have the woman crying with the snap
bubbles coming out say women can lie
this hard I mean people can cry it's
hard and still be lying
they commit I don't know what to tell
you it is what it is I mean